The one piece manga just confirmed one of
the most popular theories which is that Blackbeard
absolutely can eat a third devil fruit.
And this mind-blowing reveal comes with massive
implications for the story as Blackbeard considers
whether or not to eat the Ope Ope no mi after
defeating Trafalgar Law.
And even though Law escapes, we now know that
Blackbeard will surely be hunting for a third
supremely powerful devil fruit to pair with
his strongest devil fruits in the story.
And that’s not the only epic clash in this
chapter as we get confirmation that the former
marine admiral Aokiji is actually one of Blackbeard’s
titanic captains and he is on Pirate Island
RIGHT NOW to stop Garp from rescuing Koby.
But that is not going to be an easy feat,
as we get even more evidence that Garp is
the most insanely powerful marine in the story.
And if that wasn’t enough, we learn even
more clues about Aokiji's mysterious time
after leaving the marines and more hints about
where the elusive fourth Road Poneglyph might
be.
Starting with the epic conclusion to Law versus
Blackbeard.
In chapter 1063, we first see Law and Blackbeard
clash on Winner Island.
And in this all out battle Law used his god-like
devil fruit to fend off the darkness and earthquake
wielding Blackbeard.
But the fighting has finally reached its conclusion
as we see a bloodied and panting Blackbeard
standing over a defeated Law.
And in this scene we seem to get as close
to an answer as we’ve ever had to one of
the biggest mysteries in all of One Piece.
Ever since Marineford when Blackbeard did
the unthinkable and took Whitebeard’s devil
fruit for himself, we have always wondered
if he would be able to eat a third devil fruit.
And the answer seems to be yes, as Blackbeard
openly wonders if he should take Law’s powers
and use them or sell the coveted Ope-Ope no
mi to the highest bidder.
And while he doesn’t outright say that he
wants to eat it, we can basically assume that
he is talking about himself for a few reasons.
First, all of his other titanic captains already
have devil fruits, so unless anyone can eat
two fruits, that rules out all of them.
And I really don’t think Blackbeard would
give it to just some random member of his
crew, so that really only leaves himself as
an option to eat the fruit.
But if he decided to sell it, one group who
would definitely be interested in the fruit
is the World Government.
We’ve known they’ve been after this fruit
since we saw them try so hard to obtain it
during Law’s heart-breaking flashback.
And then during the last chapter we learned
that Blackbeard wants to officially join the
world government as a kingdom.
So maybe he could trade the Ope fruit in exchange
for membership in the world government.
But whether he wanted to eat it or trade Law’s
fruit, this mind-blowing reveal brings up
the old question of how exactly can Blackbeard
eat more than one devil fruit.
We don’t get any clues that anyone else
in his crew is able to do this, so it truly
seems that this ability is specific to Blackbeard.
But why is that?
Personally, I’m dying to know, but a few
theories we have discussed before on the channel
are that Blackbeard has multiple personalities
or that there is something weird about his
body that allows him to eat multiple devil
fruits.
Or it could be some super secret power of
the darkness fruit that we don’t yet know
about.
It is also unclear if Blackbeard would need
to kill Law in order to take his devil fruit,
as Law is clearly still alive in this chapter.
And every time we have seen devils fruits
taken or talked about being taken, it involved
someone needing to be killed.
For example, with Whitebeard’s death in
Marineford and when Burgess wanted to take
Luffy’s fruit in Dressrosa.
But while Blackbeard takes his time deciding
what to do, this scene takes a WILD turn of
events.
Law’s loyal mink polar bear, Bepo, takes
a mysterious drug which allows him to enter
the mink’s most ferociously powerful form:
Sulong.
And normally this form can only be used during
the full moon, but apparently this drug that
was developed by Chopper allows them to enter
the form whenever they want.
Which is so interesting because we are getting
more evidence that Chopper is truly becoming
a medical genius.
And in this beastly form, Bepo is able to
steal Law away and escape into the sea, leaving
the other members of Law’s crew abandoned
on the island.
Which leaves us with a super interesting question:
Where does Law go from here?
There are many possible options.
First, Egghead island should be somewhat close
by, since Law and Luffy both came to these
islands directly after leaving Wano.
So it’s possible that Bepo will take Law
to Egghead where they will encounter the Straw
Hat pirates.
And even though Law and Luffy declared their
alliance over I could see Law asking for Luffy’s
help if it meant saving his crew.
Another option, and one that personally has
me extremely excited, is that Bepo could take
Law to his home, Zou.
This would bring the enormous walking elephant
Zunesha back into the story as we only saw
it for a brief few chapters when it came to
Wano.
Clearly, Zunesha still has some role to play
in the story, so this could be one way to
reintroduce the massive elephant once again.
And even more exciting is the entire country
of minks living on Zunesha’s back.
With this new drug that can let Minks go sulong
whenever they choose, this entire country
who are allies with Luffy, just got way way
stronger.
We already saw in Wano that sulong minks can
be devastating fighters, so a whole army of
these ferocious animals would be insanely
powerful for the battles to come.
And there is no greater upcoming battle than
the race to find the one piece.
With Law defeated, we can assume that Blackbeard
has taken his copies of the Road Poneglyphs
which are necessary to reach Laugh Tale.
And we did a full breakdown of who has which
Road poneglyphs in a recent chapter review,
but basically this means Blackbeard now has
at least two of the Road Poneglyphs, and as
we will discuss in just a few minutes, he
is likely to get at least one more very soon.
But now that Law is defeated, this means that
the final players in the race to find the
One Piece are now set.
Law and Captain Kid, who was just defeated
by Shanks, are no longer serious contenders,
which just leaves Luffy, Shanks, Blackbeard,
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT character, Buggy.
Come on, you can never leave Buggy out of
these kinds of important events.
But now we have to ask what will Blackbeard
do next?
Will he pursue another strong devil fruit
to take as his own?
Or just move onto whatever his next objective
is?
And if he is going hunting for a third devil
fruit, we have to ask which power does Blackbeard
want?
Well, in this chapter, we get a hint that
he isn’t dead set on a particular devil
fruit to eat as his third power.
It seems he wasn’t sure if he wanted the
Ope fruit for himself or not, so maybe he
is still undecided or simply waiting to see
what supremely overpowered devil fruit he
can get his hands on.
But it is certainly possible that he chases
after Law and Bepo to take back the Ope powers,
but if he can’t do that there are some other
options for fruits that he could want.
And personally, it has never really made sense
for him to eat another Logia as I don’t
know how he could be darkness AND another
element at the same time.
So that leaves a Zoan power or a Parameica.
So there are a few strong Zoans Blackbeard
could target.
With Kaido defeated, Blackbeard could be after
his mythical devil fruit.
Or, with Kaido not ruling over Wano, Blackbeard
could sneak in and go after the two other
mythical fruits still on the island.
Those are Momo’s version of the dragon fruit
and Yamato’s Okuchi no Makami fruit, which
lets her turn into this wolf guardian deity.
And Blackbeard sneaking into this territory
would make sense because we just saw them
sneak into Big Mom’s territory to kidnap
Big Mom’s daughter.
Besides Wano, there is currently a large gathering
of strong devil fruit users on Egghead.
So Blackbeard could join the epic conflict
in order to steal some devil fruits such as
the Leopard fruit or, even Stussy’s unnamed
vampire-like fruit.
It is also entirely possible that Vegapunk
has a storehouse of strong devil fruits that
could be taken during the fighting.
And of course there are also the Straw Hat’s
devil fruits that Blackbeard could have his
eye on.
And speaking of Straw Hats, has anyone else
noticed that it has now been three whole chapters
since we have even seen our main characters?
How crazy is that in the middle of an arc?
But personally I’m not complaining since
we keep getting these incredible chapters
of events outside of Egghead.
But if Blackbeard doesn’t chase Law or go
to one of the other islands I just mentioned,
the most likely option is that he returns
to his home base, Pirate Island, to join the
earth shattering conflict between the increasingly
badass Garp and his former pupil, Kuzan.
And this clash will undoubtedly have a massive
effect on the future of the Blackbeard pirate
which we will discuss in full detail in just
a moment.
But one note is that since Kuzan is no longer
an admiral, we won’t use his admiral nickname
Aokiji anymore, and instead call him by his
actual name Kuzan.
But before we get to that titanic fight, we
see a flashback about the first time that
Kuzan met with Blackbeard.
We are told this event is about one year after
Kuzan lost his devastating, island-warping
battle against the current fleet admiral Akainu.
After this battle Kuzan left the marines because
he couldn’t stand taking orders from Akainu.
We aren’t told what Kuzan has been doing
in between that fight and this scene in the
flashback, but there are a number of hints
we can use to try and figure it out.
In chapter 698 we see Kuzan for the very first
time after the time skip when he saves Vice-admiral
Smoker on Punk Hazard.
And in this conversation, Kuzan’s clothes
suggest that he is still wandering as a loner
and has not yet joined the Blackbeard pirates.
I mean, just look at the differences between
this outfit and these that he is wearing as
one of Blackbeard’s titanic captains.
Clearly something changed in the few months
since Punk Hazard.
However, Blackbeard could have offered for
Kuzan to join him halfway through the two
year time skip but Kuzan might have taken
a while before accepting the offer to join
the Emperor’s crew.
Regardless, it is clear Kuzan has been acting
on his own for sometime during and after the
timeskip, which makes me wonder what exactly
he was doing.
Blackbeard even said in this chapter that
pirates can still have their own agenda’s,
so maybe Blackbeard just let’s Kuzan do
whatever he wants unless directly ordered
by Blackbeard.
But the clearest answer to all of this speculation,
and the one most people expect, is that he
has resigned from the marines and joined the
secret marine organization, Sword.
We just learned in chapter 1080 that all the
members of Sword are former marines who are
no longer affiliated with the world government
so that they can act on their own behalf.
Basically they are like Garp, who pretty much
does whatever he wants.
And the evidence for Kuzan being a member
of Sword is made even clearer when we compare
some of Kuzan’s dialogue from chapter 699
to what we just learned in the last chapter.
Take a look at what Kuzan says while talking
to Smoker.
First, he states that “You don’t have
to be affiliated with the Navy to accomplish
things” and that “There are some things
you can only see when you remain independent”.
That is also exactly how Sword was described
in chapter 1080, so it makes complete sense
that he is acting on his own beliefs as a
member of Sword.
At the end of his conversation with Smoker,
he even warns the vice-admiral about the dangers
of Doflamingo in Dressrosa and then went on
to tell the marines to not reveal that they
had seen him.
And it makes sense that he would only care
about these things if, one, he was a part
of the secret marine organization, and, two,
he planned to go undercover and didn’t want
Blackbeard finding out that he was still helping
the marines?
So personally it all lines up that he infiltrated
Blackbeard’s crew with some intention of
betraying Blackbeard.
But back to the flashback we see in this chapter,
Blackbeard arrives on the scene and three
of his titanic captains are already frozen
by Kuzan’s ice powers.
And while one of Blackbeard’s allies thinks
it would be best to kill Kuzan right away,
they instead have a jolly old time drinking
and having fun inside the bar.
And maybe Kuzan has changed since joining
the marines, but this is certainly not the
laid-back, lazy, and emotionless dude that
we are used to.
Which makes me think even more that this is
an act that he is putting on to fool Blackbeard.
And eventually Blackbeard asks Kuzan about
the man with the burn scar because he thinks
that this person might have the final Road
Poneglyph.
And this was a TRULY MASSIVE SHOCK when I
read this.
I mean, we barely learned about this mysterious
figure in chapter 1056.
Captain Kid knew about him and his connection
to the One Piece.
But if the Blackbeard crew knew about him
over a year ago, just how secretive is this
guy?
Well, we got more information about who this
might be in chapter 1066.
We learned that the giant former marine Saul,
who we thought was killed during the destruction
of Ohara, was most likely alive.
So it makes a lot of sense that he is the
man marked by flames, since he literally was
running through flames, he could have ice
burns after being frozen by Kuzan, and we
see him wrapped in bandages in this panel
right here.
And since Saul was connected to the incident
at Ohara, and those same scholars were studying
the Poneglyphs, it would be logical that Saul
could be protecting the final Road Poneglyph.
Plus We already know from Vegapunk’s flashback
that the giants of Elbaf salvaged everything
they could from Ohara, so it would certainly
be reasonable for the final Road Poneglyph
to be on Elbaf with Saul.
And while Kuzan denies knowing anything about
the man marked by flames or the final Road
Poneglyph, he could just be lying to protect
Saul, since Saul was a friend of Kuzan’s.
And yet another rumor that is hinted at in
this scene is that the man marked by flames
travels on a black ship and has some ability
to create whirlpools.
And a black ship makes me think of this ship,
which was captained by Rocks D. Xebec.
Another option is that it could be referring
to the leader of the Revolutionary army, Monkey
D. Dragon.
Whirlpools can be formed by strong winds,
and we know Dragon has some kind of wind powers,
since he basically always is accompanied by
strong winds whenever he appears in the story.
Plus, we found out recently that Dragon also
had ties to the scholars of Ohara, so it is
possible that Dragon and Saul became allies
after the events of Ohara.
But all of this makes me wonder how anyone
knows about the man marked by flames in the
first place.
If this person is Saul, then he should have
been in hiding for literally decades.
But somehow Blackbeard and even Kid had heard
rumors about him.
So are there traitors within the giants of
Elbaf?
Or is this mysterious figure someone completely
different that we haven’t met yet?
Whatever the answer, it will certainly be
just as exciting as the mouth-watering clash
between Kuzan and Garp on pirate island.
We first see Kuzan freeze Koby’s friend
and then after a brief bit of dialogue, Kuzan
freezes Garp with an Ice Ball attack, just
like he did against Whitebeard during Marineford.
And just like his legendary former rival,
Garp easily breaks out of the ice, and in
a burst of blinding speed, Garb grabs Kuzan’s
face in a haki-covered fist and slams him
into the ground with such tremendous power
that it reminds me of all the ground shattering
attacks Luffy has used to defeat his opponents
over the years.
And besides the fighting, there is a ton to
unpack from the brief dialogue between the
two.
Before they clash, Kuzan reveals that he was
actually trained by Garp sometime in the past.
This lends even more evidence to the theory
that Kuzan is secretly a member of Sword,
since Koby and Helmeppo are both members of
Sword and they were both trained by Garp.
And maybe this is just crazy copium on my
part because he certainly doesn’t look friendly
during this clash.
Seriously, if he is secretly undercover, then
he is putting a painful amount of effort into
convincing the Blackbeard pirates that he
is still on his side.
And while it appears that Garp has the advantage
in this epic battle, we simply never know
with fights in One Piece.
And this could turn around very quickly.
Maybe Kuzan isn’t taking this fight seriously
yet, or maybe the other Blackbeard titanic
captains will come in and together overwhelm
Garp.
Or maybe Garp will once again prove that he
is the strongest marine, and wipe them all
out anyway.
But that’s not all that we learn from this
legendary battle.
Since Kuzan is now confirmed to be here on
Pirate Island, this information partially
solves a mystery from chapter 1079.
For a single panel in that chapter, we saw
that one of Blackbeard’s ships is currently
just outside of Egghead island.
Previously I thought that this might be Kuzan
since it would make sense for him to join
a conflict with the world government, but
that is clearly not the case.
Since Kuzan is on pirate island, we now have
a pretty good idea of who is coming to Egghead.
Right now on Pirate island we have these five
titanic captains.
And currently accompanying Blackbeard are
these three.
Which only leaves Laffitte and Caterina Devon.
And honestly, it makes perfect sense for them
to be the ones coming to Egghead because there
is no one better at sneaking around on the
Blackbeard crew than these two.
We already know that Laffitte is super stealthy
as he even managed to sneak into Mary Geoise,
he has some hypnosis powers, and he can fly
with his wings.
But even better for trickery is Caterina Devon,
who has the shape-shifting powers of the mythical
Nine-Tailed fox devil fruit.
So together, these two form the perfect pair
to steal into the chaos of Egghead island
and take whatever they want.
It could be the copies of the Road Poneglyphs
on the Straw Hats ship, or it could be that
they have their eyes on a super strong devil
fruit that they want to capture if someone
dies.
But with one conflict wrapping up, and the
others getting even more incredible by the
chapters, I cannot wait to see who comes out
on top in these world-changing battles.
And if you want to know why the godly powers
of Garp will completely change the rest of
the story, you can watch this video right
here.
Shanks for watching.